here's a quick tutorial on how to be
miserable for the rest of your life
step one wake up whenever you want to
don't wake up at a reasonable hour
an hour that makes you feel good about
yourself make sure you wake up when
everyone has had a head start to the day
you really want to make sure you feel
like you've missed
any chance to start your day off on the
right foot and when you get out of bed
don't make your bed don't shower just
wear whatever you wore yesterday and
head downstairs
it's important that you start the day
off with little to no
self-respect feeling as grimy as
possible step 2
make sure your house is always a
complete disaster your house is filled
with many rooms
each with a specific purpose you want to
make sure that it's extremely difficult
to accomplish those purposes
the pig style will also help
subconsciously reinforce the idea that
you're a disorganized person
whose life is not in order this is an
extremely important belief to have when
trying to remain miserable
step 3 procrastinate when the thought
dawns on you to do something productive
like
clean your disgusting kitchen just
ignore that feeling after all
you just woke up and you have so much
time later in the day to get that done
you want to get in the habit of
delegating all your life's problems to
the future version of yourself
who will probably have a lot more
motivation and energy than you do right
now
step 4 look busy after you sit down to
do some work
open up a word document to help yourself
feel like you're being productive
give your document a nice title and then
immediately open up reddit
instagram facebook and twitter just to
check if you missed anything
you see it doesn't really matter what
you do as long as you're sitting on your
desk
and that word document is open it'll
help trick your conscience into thinking
you're doing work
but you won't be getting any further in
life step 5
wait for opportunities never be
proactive with finding new opportunities
to grow your career
or meet new people wait for all of that
to come knocking on your door
after all if it's gonna happen it's
gonna happen you'll meet the girl of
your dreams one day and
things will kind of just work out you'll
probably also land your dream job
if you just wait long enough anyways the
important thing is to not take action
don't try to figure out the most
effective way to get what you want
just wait until things work out step 6
be default no when a friend asks you to
go out for a drink
just say no after all you're super busy
these days and have a lot of work to do
when your boss gives you the opportunity
to lead a meeting at work
try to find an excuse to slink out of it
the key here is to give everyone the
impression that they should just
let you do your own thing be so good at
saying no
that people just stop asking you to do
anything
step 7 be suspicious of people never
give people the benefit of the doubt
believe that everyone basically just
wants to take advantage of you
and because of this you should be
guarded and put up walls to protect
yourself emotionally
assume the smiles people give you are
fake and that their motives are
malevolent
step 8 never fix the things you dislike
about yourself
continue to engage in activities that
make you feel
subhuman and weak never prove to
yourself that you can overcome obstacles
or better yourself
never attempt to transcend your vices or
change your lifestyle for the better
subscribe to the idea that people can't
change
so you shouldn't try step 9 focus on
things you can't control
as often as possible get pissed off at
the traffic
the government the pandemic you really
want to reinforce the idea that the
world is messed up
and there's nothing you can do about it
focus on the shortcomings of others
the failings of your country and the
state of the economy
maintain a constant external locus of
control
over all the events in your life this
will really help you feel powerless
and if you're trying to be miserable
that's perfect step 10
use fear as motivation make the fear of
negative consequence your primary
motivator for everything you do
set up deadlines that frighten you and
punish yourself for failing to meet them
use white knuckle tactics to force
yourself into productivity and remind
yourself constantly
that your entire life could fall apart
if you don't keep your head above water
step 11 only do what is comfortable let
your comfort zone be the authority on
what you do
and don't do if it's not comfortable
don't do it
avoid discomfort at all costs and
participate
only in activities that are familiar and
effortless
don't concern yourself with gaining
fresh perspectives or
novel experiences stay in your lane
operating your wheelhouse
step 12 believe you're special behave
like you're entitled to things on the
basis that you're just
different than everyone else assume that
the people that have what you want in
life
just don't deserve it as much as you do
always regard yourself as talented
unique one-of-a-kind this will really
help you develop an
outsider complex which will make it
difficult to open up to other people or
see things from their perspective
but since you don't want to do any of
that uncomfortable stuff anyways
that's perfect step 13 see life not as
it is
but how you wish it to be daydream of a
day where things are better
fantasize about a life where all your
problems are gone you want to make sure
you mentally escape
as much as possible to distract you from
the obstacles in front of you
pour your mental energy not into fixing
your problems
or improving yourself but into building
up this fantasy to be as detailed as
possible
reflect daily about what you would buy
if you won the lottery
or became a celebrity constantly compare
your life to this fiction
and become resentful at the
juxtaposition so
if suffering is what you're after and
you crave the daily strife
then you're in luck because if you
follow this advice you'll be miserable
for the rest of your life
this video was sponsored by audible the
audiobook i'm currently diving into
is green lights by matthew mcconaughey
it's been on amazon's best seller list
for 23 straight weeks now and i wanted
to see what the hype is about
and sure enough i'm really enjoying it
so far i think the audible version is
especially enjoyable because it's
narrated by mcconaughey himself
which really helps his lessons and tales
resonate with the reader
it really feels like you're getting to
know matthew mcconaughey personally
and he just seems like a cool guy to
know for those of you who don't know
audible is the leading provider of
spoken word entertainment and audiobooks
ranging from bestsellers to celebrity
memoirs motivation
productivity and so much more like
original entertainment
and even podcasts audible recently
launched their newest plan audible plus
and with audible plus you get access to
their entire plus catalog
which is filled with thousands and
thousands of select originals
audiobooks and podcasts including
ad-free versions of popular shows as
well as
exclusive series one of my favorite
things about audible
is that if you decide to cancel your
membership for whatever reason
at any point you still keep your entire
library of audiobooks
including the audiobooks that you got
for free using their credit system so
it's kind of a no-brainer so to sign up
for your free 30-day trial click the
link in the description below
visit audible.com better ideas or text
better ideas to 500-500 once again to
sign up for your free 30-day trial
click the link in the description below
visit audible.com
better ideas or text better ideas to
500-500
[Music]
you